well the pro-gun right has gone
absolutely nuts after the assassination
of the former japanese prime minister
shinzo abe now the assassination itself
is a major major political story uh it's
been widely covered over the last three
days and there's not so much to add
about that it's a
story of global significance and
japanese significance etc and most of
what there is to say about that has been
said i want to focus on the reaction to
this assassination which was done with a
firearm from the pro-gun right in the
united states who has rallied around
this assassination to say look
gun control is strict in japan
and a former prime minister
was assassinated and this proves that it
doesn't matter what you do in terms of
guns this proves that restricting guns
doesn't make a difference and of course
they're completely wrong and we're going
to look at the data and we're going to
make an empirical case for why that is
now just to sort of set the stage
um
what we have learned about this
assassination this is per npr
um political motivations have been
denied by the shooter he told police the
attack had been planned for months abe
was shot from behind in the western city
of nara while speaking at a campaign
event police arrested tatsuya yamagami a
41 year old at the scene yamagami uh an
unemployed former sailor in the maritime
armed forces of japan confessed to the
killing for which he used a handmade
firearm according to police and that's
an element
of the reaction that we are hearing from
many which is look even if you restrict
firearms completely to the point of
making them illegal people will just
make them at home and we're going to get
back to that but the most important top
line thing to understand
is that although there has been
a killing this is you know last week we
had this caller who said david why why
aren't anecdotes okay
to understand the world around us
anecdotes are our experience and the
point i made was
if you extrapolate from an anecdote you
often will be wrong and the fact that
someone was killed with a gun in japan
misses the reality that the rate of gun
death in japan is a fraction of what it
is in the united states the numbers are
actually quite stunning
two important uh bits of data first of
all
very few people own guns in japan and i
think
no nobody denies that part in the u.s
there's an estimate of 120 guns per 100
people that that's more than one gun per
person in the united states whereas in
japan it's 0.3 guns per 100 people so
that's the gun ownership rate and then
if you continue in looking at this bbc
article you see that gun deaths in japan
are extremely rare in the u.s there are
seven deaths
by firearm per 100 000 people whereas in
japan it's 0.03
japan's rate of gun death
is um
a fraction and in fact the u.s rate of
gun death is 23 000 percent higher than
the rate in japan that's not a typo 23
000
higher so then you go to well
the person made the gun at home
so you can't prevent that well imagine
if the only way to shoot someone was to
make the gun at home think about that if
you could if that was really the way if
you wanted to shoot someone you had to
make a firearm in your house
imagine how much lower gun violence
would be because most people aren't
going to do that
guns are not illegal in japan they're
just much more difficult to obtain and
this has worked at making the gun
violence the gun death rate almost zero
if to buy a gun in japan you need to
take a firearms class
pass a written exam which is only held
three times a year so you can't just say
well i want it tomorrow it's held three
times a year you've got to get a
doctor's note uh saying you're mentally
fit and have no history of drug abuse
you have to ask for a permit
to do firing training that can take a
month you have to be interviewed by
police and explain why you need a gun
you have to pass a review of your
criminal history and gun possession
record employment involvement with
organized crime debt relationships with
friends all these things you then apply
for a gun powder permit you take a one
day training class have to pass a firing
test
at that point you can get a certificate
from a gun dealer
describing the gun that you want if you
are trying to hunt you have to get a
hunting license to show i'm really
getting this in order to hunt you then
have to get a gun safe and an ammo
locker the police have to inspect it and
make sure that it's in compliance you
then do a final kind of overall
background review and after that step 13
or 18 depending on whether you consider
each of these things one or sometimes
two things then you can actually go and
buy a gun
so the anecdotal reaction this is the
this is the epitome of why anecdotes
aren't useful the anecdotal reaction is
strict gun laws
and there's a shooting none of the gun
laws work
the systemic empirical reaction is
strict gun laws
very small rate of gun ownership guns
aren't illegal but all of this leads to
a tiny tiny rate of gun death in the
country of japan yes
a person was killed with a gun and it
was notable and it was a known person
because it's a former prime minister
it's like if bill clinton or george w
bush were uh or donald trump were killed
with a firearm it is notable it's major
news
but
the gun violence rate is nothing in
japan compared to that of the united
states and that really should be the big
takeaway so
i was involved in a whole bunch of
different twitter spats as this was
going on with people saying this this
proves that you can't prevent gun
violence no actually this proves that
you can and in fact this story is a
major story in japan not only because of
the person that was killed the former
prime minister but because anyone was
killed with a gun at all because it is
so rare
in the entire country and japan has a
large population i think it's about 80
million um you have to adjust for that
it's smaller than the us but that rate
is tiny for a country with so many
people and in fact let me just double
check japan population 125 million
actually so it's an even even bigger
country making the the number of gun
deaths even smaller that's the takeaway
their policy has worked
hey this is uh this almost seems like a
saturday night live skit
fox news is now warning
there may be too many jobs too many
people might be working and this could
be a warning sign for the economy
how how is that possible well like with
everything with almost everything
there's sometimes like a kernel or a
grain of truth somewhere up the chain in
the analysis and i'm using the analysis
the term analysis extraordinarily
loosely and we have actually previously
spoken about this oh if inflation is up
that's bad but if inflation is down
that's also bad because it signals there
might be a demand collapse and either
way we're heading towards a recession
with most economic indicators taken to
their extreme you can argue that either
very high or very low isn't good but the
new one on fox is the jobs report might
be too good this could be bad for the
economy after spending a long time
saying where are the jobs joe biden and
focusing on the labor participation rate
so let's look at a couple of screen
captures from fox news first one uh job
gains spur concerns of rising inflation
so let's explore that how does that work
well uh the more people that are working
the more people that have money to buy
things if more people want to buy the
same limited number of things you would
expect that prices could go up it's just
there's more demand so people selling
stuff if you've got a hundred people who
want to buy your sneakers you're going
to be able to charge more than if
there's only one person who wants to buy
your sneakers okay there's there's a
there's a kernel of that there but all
of a sudden now the problem is the jobs
numbers are too good that's kind of
weird but it is fox news it is maria
bartoromo after all another uh headline
america's employment crisis
there are too many job openings there's
too many companies hiring compared to
the number of people looking for jobs
and they put up that this is they call
this a crisis there's 11 million job
openings but there's only six million
unemployed people
that's a crisis all of a sudden now
remember when it's convenient to them
they say well the official number of
unemployed workers doesn't reflect the
real number because you're only
considered unemployed if you're actively
looking for a job if you are demoralized
by not finding a job you'd still like
one but you've just sort of given up
you're no longer considered unemployed
so the right loves to say
that the real number of unemployed
people is millions and millions higher
than the official number because you've
got all these people uh working
part-time who would like to be working
full-time and that's not reflected in
the numbers people who have just given
up because they can't find a job so now
all of a sudden they don't mention that
now they just say hey there's 11 million
open jobs and 6 million unemployed
workers the other funny thing about this
is they insist that immigrants legal and
illegal are coming to the united states
taking all of our jobs and making it
harder for the american born worker to
find a job well if your new argument
is that there's a shortfall of five and
a half million people there's five and a
half million more jobs than people
wouldn't you want those
immigrants to come in to work some of
these jobs so it's all completely and
totally incoherent now there's a real
economic conversation to have here and
i'm glad to have it it's not a partisan
conversation at least in principle
although the solutions that are often
proposed become extraordinarily partisan
we've talked before
no matter what numbers there are with
most indicators you can make the case
that at one extreme or the other it
could be bad for the economy now
sky is falling headlines get way more
attention the economists and the
financial analysts who predict crashes
uh get way more clicks than the people
who say hey you know what things will
probably be more or less okay over the
medium term when it comes to
the inflation numbers
we've started to see a turnaround in the
messaging from the right the first
messaging was there's so much inflation
nobody can afford anything this is a
disaster for the economy because things
are going to get so expensive nobody's
going to buy stuff that'll hurt
businesses the businesses will have to
fire people it's going to be a recession
okay as we now have seen gas prices
decline for nearly a consecutive month
we talked about last week that talked
about that last week as the jobs numbers
continue to be really really good
the new thing is uh oh if inflation
comes down and people
all of a sudden now um stop demanding
stuff and that's what's causing the
inflation to go down we're going to have
potentially a deflationary spiral a
demand collapse and that's going to be
terrible because people aren't going to
be buying stuff and it'll be terrible
terrible for the economy it's just the
other side of the same coin when you
look at prices and inflation to the
extreme
the reality is pretty boring okay the
reality is it's very rare
not impossible but it's very rare to
have a recession
when you have such
uh you're so close to full employment
and we have a steady rate of inflation
which is slowly coming down that's an
important thing that's often not
mentioned inflation has been high and i
don't
i'm not pretending that it hasn't been a
problem it's been a problem inflation
has been high but it's now for several
months been quite steady there's no
escalating inflation where it's year
over year
well look it looks like it's about eight
percent it's about nine it's 10 11 it's
12. it's been kind of steady at this
high sevens low eights number and it's
slowly uh likely going to start coming
down recessions are not particularly
common in that scenario where
the employment situation looks good and
businesses generally speaking or looking
to hire and inflation is steady is it
impossible that we would get a recession
no it's not impossible but it's not
particularly likely and that makes for
pretty boring economic analysis but it
is the reality as the numbers point to
so far so the new one from fox
the economy might be too good
for its own good
find me on twitter at deepakman let me
know if this one surprises you
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so a little later in today's show we're
going to talk about the 2022 midterm
outlook kind of looking into the 2024
election outlook there's some
interesting things going on already
interesting polling interesting betting
numbers and a lot of different things
the context in which this happening is a
in which this is happening is a series
of increasingly unhinged candidates many
of them supported by the failed former
president donald trump and one such um
example of what we're seeing we saw this
weekend as donald trump flew up to
anchorage alaska to hold a rally really
just in opposition to lisa murkowski
lisa murkowski is the current
alaska senator she is a republican but
she is a republican that is not
particularly a deferential to donald
trump and if that's the case trump
doesn't like you and trump will try to
get you
booted out of office and that's exactly
what donald trump did in alaska he also
had uh sarah palin former vice
presidential candidate and current
congressional candidate sarah palin
speak at the event we're going to look
at it i will tell you many of these
clips are extraordinarily disturbing in
how stupid they indicate the country has
gotten now one of the things donald
trump did is he used the f word and it's
very cool i guess when you're a
republican to use the f word even if
you're a presidential candidate or a
former president even though the
republican party claims to be the party
of civility and moral values and
pro-family and christianity and
godliness and decency and character they
love
the f-bomb and just imagine as you watch
and listen to this clip how would they
have reacted if barack obama had dropped
an f-bomb in a speech i mean remember
once barack obama
didn't wear a suit jacket in the oval
office and they went bonkers once barack
obama put his feet up on the desk in the
oval office and they said this is such a
disgrace and here it's very different
here they cheer it and they love it
hit him on the left i'd hit him on the
right
i'd hit him in the center right
that's pretty cool right when the
president swears it's very relatable and
he's a man of the people and all of this
stuff now maybe the epitome of the cult
moment we've we've talked many times
this is a cult
there's no question that this is the
cult they deify trump in a way that is
completely cult-like but this is maybe
the epitome
starting with a glitch trump tried to
start his conclusion which he always
does by saying in conclusion
and he almost said in collusion he
glitched very badly one of these brain
glitches and in order to cover it he
immediately aborted the teleprompter
read and started talking about a couple
or it might be a son and it might be a
mother and son or it might be a couple i
i genuinely can't tell what it is um
he who were wearing shirts that have
trump's face all over them he talked
about how he wants their shirt and they
i guess he was kind of kidding but they
quite literally took their shirts off
these are the shirts they wore they took
them off to give the shirt to trump so
this all starts with trump glitching
badly on in conclusion and it goes
downhill very quickly and look at the
cultish nature of this
include
i love this guy's shirt i tell you
you know i'd love to have you get up
here come on get up here let me see get
up here get this guy up here come here i
love this guy any guy wears a shirt like
that how can you not love him look at
that beautiful yeah would you help him
up
taylor help him up come on you're a
strong guy come here i just wanted and
you'll notice that as these people come
up they they look visibly disoriented by
what's going on
i like that one
[Music]
i want this shirt i'm going to wear it
to the next rally
now you and i can tell that's a joke but
they end up taking their shirts off
[Music]
i want it
[Applause]
and honestly if you're only listening
you're probably better off because the
cringe in what we're seeing here is
bizarre
[Applause]
thank you i want that shirt all right so
moments later they actually did take
their shirts off and we have an image of
these individuals and the image has not
been photoshopped they uh they took
their shirts off and it is the epitome
the epitome of the cult moment back to
some uh more substantial things donald
trump is now afraid to even use the word
vaccine this is very interesting in this
next clip donald trump tries to take
credit for the things he did during the
pandemic and one of the things trump
loves to take credit for is the vaccine
he doesn't actually say the word he says
we did it much faster than they said we
would but he doesn't say vaccine because
his audience is so anti-vaxx we did a
hell of a job never got credit for that
more people died under biden you saw
that and the job we did
with covedor as some people call it to
be more accurate the china virus
but we did so much in terms of
therapeutics and a word that i'm not
allowed to mention but i'm still proud
of that word he's he's not allowed to
mention it but he's proud of it because
we did it we did that we did that in
nine months and it was supposed to take
five years to 12 years nobody else could
have done it but i'm not mentioning it
in front of my people but that's
interesting he's he's conceding if he
uses the word vaccine in front of his
people they will boo but that thing that
thing we did in months instead of years
another moment this is a classic trump
always trying to be relatable so he will
mention places in the state where he's
speaking here he says let's go to inside
passage the slopes of
denali
to the waters of glacier bay that's our
beautiful place
and from the forests of the interior to
the majestic vistas of
the inside passage does anybody know the
inside passage
anybody want to go there tonight
beautiful name the inside let's go to
the inside passage tonight right you can
tell trump really familiar with the
state of alaska based on that a number
of verbal misfires here he referred to
the uh newest supreme court justice
katanji brown jackson as kachenji
she voted to approve joe biden's radical
left justice kachenji
brown
jackson the most far left
justice in history the arguably the most
qualified justice in history another
misfire just a very glitchy evening for
trump trump trying to say elon musk and
he says leon and it all goes downhill
i tell you what
elon
elon right is not gonna buy twitter
where did you hear that before
leon's i tell you what
leon and then lastly now a staple of
these rallies the overt
crass
transphobic portion of the speech
we will also keep men
out of
women's sports
major
issues right
the swimmer
the young swimmer she wanted to break
that record 1 16 of a second she was
going to do it
and she looked over and she said hello
to people that she's grown up with she's
seen him she's a top top swimmer she
looks left and she sees them hi hi you
know they hate each other but they're
you know they're competing hi hi they
hate her
she hates them that's the way life goes
right
then she looks over waves and then she
sees this
guy
they they say i mean this is supposed to
be a technically
correct area a person with a man's body
okay it's a man's body
so they seized this person with a man's
body and he's a giant he's that big
guy's wingspan
i'm not even gonna do the rest of it
because it's so overtly crass and
horrifying but that is now a staple of
these events so alaska a rally in alaska
everything going horribly wrong
and then it became sarah palin's
opportunity to speak and let's talk
about that next do you remember that
quaint era in american politics in 2008
where we thought sarah palin is the
craziest that anyone involved in
politics will be sarah palin is the
wackiest sarah palin is the most
cartoonish and ignorant and unqualified
we're never going to see anything uh uh
below sarah palin and of course we were
very wrong and then came trump and
trumpism and a bevy of candidates uh
worse than sarah palin but
sarah palin has gotten even worse over
the last couple of decades sarah palin
is now running for a member of congress
in alaska she was invited to speak both
before trump at the trump rally in
anchorage and during
and it was really really weird sarah
palin called on alaskan chicks
to show people
what makes them women
now
if you've uh
looked at you know
maybe certain medical journals lately uh
the question of
showing what makes you a woman
is an interesting thing to demand women
do
but that's what sarah palin did check it
out to our leaders not being able to
tell us
they don't know
what a woman is
hey all you alaskan chicks out there
maybe you can show them tell them what
real woman yeah
show everybody how you know that you're
a woman a very very strange request then
sarah palin was invited up during
trump's speech to speak
almost completely incoherent now we've
talked before
sometimes sarah palin really struggles
to use words
and then to combine them
and to try to communicate things of
meaning
this is maybe the worst i've ever seen
her a lot of people ask me how did you
know that you know that president trump
that donald j trump was going to be the
best president that we'd ever had how
did how did you think to uh to get out
there and endorse him early when
gosh you know there was a lot of
party pressure on me and others to
endorse you know established candidates
and all that
and
i knew well personally speaking for
years
even trump is confused by this and he'll
accept any praise but this he's like
what is she talking about donald trump
watched what the fake media the fake
news the lame stream media put my kids
through okay
remember this
the things that you guys did to my kids
by the way the pointing to the back
nobody's covering these rallies it's
basically newsmax right side
broadcasting
and if i don't have anything better
going on i'll cover their coverage
there's not whatever they think of as
the fake news media there's none of it
there nobody's even talking about these
things donald trump he would write me a
note and he would say hang in there
the people who know you they love you
they know the truth about your family
sitting right over there god bless you
hi trig
right
and i knew that this man cared about
family yeah trump really deeply
spiritual and also really a family man
um at another point sarah palin
suggested that the right not retreat but
rather reload which is really a great
message when we're plagued by mass
shootings
my dad no he was all about no you
stiffen your spine you use what they
throw at you as fuel
let it strengthen and fortify you
and you fight for what is right well my
dad's words exactly were
don't retreat reload
now that's a message the crowd can get
behind thinly veiled allusions to
violence at a time during we are with
which we are plagued by mass shootings a
couple uh other real quick ones in this
segment sarah palin discusses donald
trump's balls
out of all of them because i knew them
all he was the only one who had the
balls to take on the fake media fake
news and to take on hillary clinton
yeah clinton
um and lastly sarah palin during her
speech
using the term plandemic which of course
is
a buzzword for the utter
bottom feeding worst of the worst covet
conspiracy
theorists this is life-changing what's
coming up here in the midterms the
changes that are needed and it's no
longer democrat versus republican
this is all about control versus freedom
it's
it's good versus evil
it is a spiritual battle
[Applause]
they use the pandemic as an example in
order to achieve a goal of controlling
you the plan endemic so this now is
welcomed
by
what has become the mainstream of the
republican party
trumpism and later in the show or maybe
tomorrow if i don't get to it we are
going to take a deep look at polling
data
is trumpism currently dominant in the
republican party it's an important
question in thinking about these
midterms and about 2024. we're going to
take a quick break all of these clips if
you were just listening today and you
have a sort of morbid sick curiosity as
to what it looked like we will have
these clips on our instagram at david
pakman show and then after the break
we'll look at a couple of interviews
with rally goers and i will warn you
it's just as bad or worse uh than sarah
palin
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right so we're
going to kind of close our coverage of
this wacky weekend in alaska we looked
at the trump rally we looked at sarah
palin we're now going to look at uh some
interviews with rally attendees and one
of the things we realized was that trump
supporters in alaska are just as
delusional and just as disconnected from
reality as those in other parts of the
country alaska often gets this
reputation sort of like vermont of being
a different type of place where left and
right don't mean the same things and the
republicans are more reasonable and the
liberals are more conservative and you
know all these different things because
of its rural and all these stuff maybe
to some degree that that's true and in
fact i think it is true to some degree
but no shortage of whacked out
delusional
participants i guess in the political
system
here some women are asked what are the
main issues that are of concern to you
the main political issues women in
alaska what are you worried about
um i'm not gonna preview what they say
let's listen to what they say
what's the most important issue that you
guys are concerned about as alaska oh
space force all right qr keeling
the support of our veterans the healing
i'm sorry trafficking specifically what
kind of trafficking uh human trafficking
are you worried about our southern
border
yes everything
i think eventually they'll end up going
back to their own countries with nasara
jazara kicking in
right now
there's a lot there
so
the main issues for women in alaska
conservative women principled
conservative women are
space force
uh which is doing nothing right now
qr codes killing people i think is what
she said
veterans okay veterans healing
healing's great but from what and in
what way
trafficking
and the southern border of the united
states which is quite removed both
geographically and politically from
what's happening in alaska alaska of
course sharing a border with canada
these are the issues that they say are
the most important now at the end you
might have heard that this woman
mentions nasara and jasara they're going
back to their own countries with nasara
jasar kicking in okay when that i
watched that uh on saturday during our
stream
i didn't know what on earth this woman
was talking about
nasara is an acronym for the national
economic security and recovery act
these were some proposed economic
reforms suggested during the 1990s by a
guy named harvey francis barnard
who wanted to replace the income tax
with the national sales tax and get rid
of compound interest on secured loans
and go back to a
currency backed by two types of precious
metals all these different things and
it's kind of become a cult-like thing
and uh the idea that people are going to
go back to mexico because of nassar i
mean it is
so out there that even many conspiracy
theorists have no idea what it's about
so that's what women in alaska say
they care about here's a guy who is sort
of a medical marvel listen to this guy's
voice he seems to have something in his
throat not not his not his uh mouth not
his nose but his throat
i've never heard someone speak like this
in an extended way i asked some doctor
friends of mine what exactly is going on
here they said they don't know this
what you're about to hear is defying the
medical knowledge of multiple doctors
check this out look what he did for us i
mean come on man
he's a he's a businessman
he's showing people up
i i can't even pretend to speak that way
they can't they don't know where they're
at because he
knows ins and outs of business
he got all of our prices down our taxes
down our gas down our food down
demands a dream now not only did trump
not do any of those things
i tried uh holding water in my mouth to
try to sound like that i tried sort of
like speaking through a gargle i could
not replicate that
and what a wild wild day in anchorage
alaska so the supporters also
um
crediting trump with things he didn't do
imagining new conspiracy i mean just
completely all over the place
and we have to remember
some of these people vote not all of
them some of them show up at these
rallies they travel all over going to
rallies and they they say they're
devoted to trump they're like no i was
working that day or i wasn't working i
was just doing nothing and i didn't go
and vote
this
group of folks
will determine
who controls the house and senate uh
after january of 2023 based on how they
vote this november so
wild
but not to be ignored as a political
constituency all right absolute last
thing on the wacky weekend in anchorage
alaska
uh the asinine anchorage at alaska
weekend um my pillow ceo mike lindell
did show up at the rally he claimed that
votes were stoled from donald trump in
alaska now i know
english is my second language
but
votes were stoled from donald trump
sounds wacky
and it also sounds untrue trump won in
alaska by the way do you all know here
in alaska over 29 000 votes were stolen
from donald trump
oh god i mean it's uh
the you saturday night live is going to
be out of business you all know here in
alaska over 29 000 votes were stole from
donald trump right
[Applause]
so
it happened everywhere in our country
and uh as you all know
i've said it we have to get rid of the
machines and the voting machines right
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines now remember that
in alaska donald trump won easily in
2020
um
52-42 very very easy win
but pillow is convinced votes were
stoled from donald trump and then lastly
i know at this point
it's indistinguishable from satire but
mike pillow has a new date for donald
trump being reinstated and it's next
month it's about five six weeks away
either august 20th or 21st it will be
the biggest
thing
in our lifetimes
um
and it might be what gets donald trump
finally reinstated this is so exciting
because it's all going to lead up
everybody too and i've got to say this
august 20th and 21st the biggest event
this country in our lifetime i believe
it's the most important event you're
ever for
in our lifetime what this is going to do
this will be in springfield missouri
live stream to the world the natural
place of course for the biggest event of
our lifetime i mean no offense to
springfield missouri but surprising
certainly that that's where the biggest
event is going to take place
and it's a two-day event it's invite
only you guys will be there yeah you
said that it's an invite-only so it's in
spring
missouri yes springfield missouri is so
important they'll be if you know the
invites will be going out these will be
influencers podcasters grassroots um
it'll be uh
church leaders okay and when we do this
everybody imagine every state will be
getting up there saying uh you know
here's our footprint you're all going to
hear what the good going where's our
hope you know and then the next day will
be everything of uh
what what your state can do individually
to get to yep so very very clear it's
going to be an incredible august 20th
and 21st now you guys may or may not
remember but mike pillow during my
interview with him actually said i could
go to his symposium if i wanted that he
referred to it as the symbolsium but i
think it was a cyber symposium he said
if i wanted to go to that i could he
gave me his personal cell phone number
maybe i mean i know that there's so many
church leaders that are going to be
there that they might not have room for
me but should i contact pillow and say
sir i'd love to go to the biggest event
of our lifetimes and and check out
what's going to go on and how every
state is going to do this or maybe i'll
just stay home i don't know let me know
what you think i should do so that
closes the loop
on this wild and wacky weekend asinine
anchorage alaska rally
uh not particularly full it was a 5 000
seat venue
whose upper deck was not
completely sold out there were actually
seats everywhere so i know it's alaska
and there's not that many people there
so maybe that's what's to blame maybe
the glisten and shine of trump
is receding actually trump was
glistening a lot but that was he was
sweating on saturday night
we will look at the data coming up soon
so that does it on this topic for today
we're going to take a quick break we are
going to review
an absolute clinic master class by pete
budej on fox news over the weekend we're
going to talk about
um
these boring
gun talking points being shut down by
senator dick durbin we have a lot still
to come
facebook.com davidpakmanshow make sure
you give us a like and we will be right
back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
i have a great clip today of pete budege
just crushing a mayonnaise-brained fox
news host who tries to do
the same old thing to mayor pete who is
now secretary of transportation pete
buddha judge so here's the the kind of
setup uh as many of you know
or may have heard
uh supreme court justice brett kavanaugh
recently
had to deal with protesters at a
restaurant and in the aftermath of this
and brett kavanaugh leaving through the
back door people started talking about
the right to have dinner at restaurants
and the right to privacy and all of
these crazy things in the context of
what's happening with abortion laws and
the fact that there have been uh
protests at uh abortion clinics family
planning clinics that that provide
abortion services for so long and they
are intimidatory and predatory against
women who just want to go and and get
procedures done they're it's a medical
location the contrast is unbelievable
truly
and in the midst of this
a pete buddha judge's husband
put out a tweet talking about oh you
know right to privacy and kind of poking
fun at the absurdity and the double
standard of these right wingers so mayor
pete goes on fox news and the host tries
to pull the hole is it appropriate for
the husband of a you know little
puts on a clinic truly excellent we've
talked about his skills before
it's hard to find a time where he goes
on fox news and doesn't humiliate the
host and the entire apparatus of fox
news so let's just jump into it and
we'll talk about it as we watch it your
husband tweeted after
uh justice brett kavanaugh left a
washington restaurant due to protesters
the tweet reads sounds like he just
wanted some privacy to make his own
dining decisions
is that appropriate sir
look when uh public officials go into
public life we should expect two things
one you should always be free from
violence harassment and intimidation and
two you're never going to be free from
criticism or peaceful protest people
exercising their first amendment rights
and that's what happened in this case
remember the justice never even came
into contact with these protesters that
reportedly that's an important thing he
did he became aware that they were out
front and he left through the back door
see or hear them and these protesters
are upset because a right an important
right that the majority of americans
support was taken away
not only the right to choose by the way
but but this justice was part of the
process of stripping away the right to
privacy as long as i've been alive
settled vice law in the united states
and listen to the fox host trying to
interject has been that the constitution
protected a right to privacy and that
has now been thrown out the window by
justices including justice kavanaugh who
as i recall swore up and down
in front of god and everyone including
the united states congress that they
were going to leave settled case law
alone so yes people are upset they're
going to exercise their first amendment
rights and as long as that's peaceful
that's protected compare that for
example to the reality that as a country
right now we're reckoning with the fact
that a mob summoned by the former
president all right well let me follow
him
don't make that don't go into that
direction pete please united states
capital for the purpose of overthrowing
the election and very nearly succeeded
in preventing the peaceful transfer of
power but i think common sense can tell
the difference but as a high profile
public figure sir what's funny is pete
spent 90 seconds explaining why the
question is ridiculous
and the host just basically repeats the
question
are you comfortable with protesters
protesting when you and your husband go
to dinner at a restaurant
protesting peacefully outside in a
public space sure look i can't even tell
you the number of spaces venues and
scenarios where i've been protested and
the bottom line is this any public
figure should always always be free from
violence intimidation and harassment but
should never be free from criticism or
people exercising their first amendment
rights pete buddha judge is really
really good at this and these are the
types of things where
these
this plays well you know tens of
millions of views in the kind of online
sphere youtube and twitter etc
uh but the bigger issue is lots of
people are never exposed to these types
of confrontations of the absurdity of
the arguments they're making
it's okay to protest outside an abortion
clinic where women are making medical
decisions and receiving treatment and
grappling with difficult decisions
but morton's steakhouse out front while
kavanaugh is inside and doesn't even
come into contact with the protesters
we're so supposed to believe that that
is
in some way unacceptable and with all of
these these things
all of the tone policing and decorum
there are major double standards we
talked about one earlier on in the show
barack obama was regularly criticized
for these little tiny meaningless things
oh he took off his suit jacket in the
oval office he wore a tan suit at a
serious event he put his feet up on the
desk at the white house and trump drops
an f-bomb while attacking his political
opponents at his rally in anchorage over
the weekend and it's not just that the
crowd doesn't mind they cheer
they celebrate the fact that trump is
swearing
by their logic very unbecoming of a
former president so
uh a lot of people i know are saying
well david what if this happened to you
this has happened to me i mean i i there
have been people
at events that i've done
who were in the room and this was a
while ago and they stood up and they
they tried to kind of take over the
event by asking these attack sort of
questions uh to the point where the
organizers said hey guy okay we're that
that's good you've made your point we're
now moving on at a restaurant i believe
it was last summer i told the story of
an anti-semitic confrontation and it was
not someone coming up to me and saying
hey you know david i know your show
and i disagree with you about your take
on the israeli-palestinian conflict and
i'd love to talk to you about my
perspective that that that would be fine
let me have my dinner and then we we can
talk about that no it was
a screaming imperialist jew bastard at
me from across the room
uh while i'm with my friends having
dinner and hey you know what it's not
comfortable but what is the argument
that it's illegal or what exactly is it
that they are saying oh well it's the
appropriateness of the husband of the
secretary of transportation supporting
protesters who kavanaugh never even came
into [ __ ] come on guys give me a break
and so pete doing an excellent job
he would be
again we're i'm talking here about
optics and skill
he would be a very reasonable
presidential candidate
now more well known than he was last
time around i find him very interesting
highly skilled and he did an excellent
job there let's now look at another
example from fox news from over the
weekend uh senator dick durbin a
democrat appeared on fox news and he
represents illinois so he was
understandably asked about this horrific
mass shooting in highland park highland
park is a swanky suburb of chicago it is
not chicago
and the uh the host much like with uh
pete buda judge same host by the way
tries these tired repetitive talking
points and says hey if it's all about
gun laws
chicago has really strict gun laws why
was there a shooting in chicago if there
are strict gun laws and of course the
shooting wasn't in chicago and dick
durbin visibly just exhausted by this
tired line of questioning highland park
before this is over to be fair though if
it were just about gun laws wouldn't
chicago would some of the toughest gun
laws in the country be a safer city
let me tell you something quickly
highland park is not chicago
it's a suburb of chicago a small town a
great small town it's the first place
you would have chosen to go to fourth of
july parade with your son or grandson or
granddaughter it's a it's a wonderful
community and to say oh chicago is so
dangerous yes it's dangerous but so is
saint louis and sword towns jackson
mississippi and others have a murder
rate as well it's a fact that we've
proliferated so many guns the police
that i sit down with privately on a
regular basis say senator you just don't
have any idea how many guns are out
there and they're so easily accessible
now the gun industry has made a lot of
money out of this but america is not
safer because of it so listen
let me be clear i want to express my
heartfelt condolences to the people of
highland park right yes other than just
attacking everything i uh we do feel bad
for for the victims that the fox host
gets on the record there so there's like
three different things here okay first
of all highland park is not chicago dick
durbin doing a good job of pointing that
out and the idea that oh it's urban it's
urban gun violence highland park is like
a swanky it's your prototypical
wealthy suburb of sorts and there's lots
of you know the suburb in a sense
originated in the uh suburban chicago
area and it's your prototypical suburb
it was not in chicago it was close
though second layer this whole thing of
the dangerous cities run by democrats
democrats are more likely to live in
cities than republicans and so cities
tend to be run by democrats safe cities
and unsafe cities in addition there are
lots of cities lots there there are you
know 10
uh notable cities
run by republicans that are not
particularly safe cities and they never
want to talk about that but the third
layer that i want to mention again
is
from chica from dangerous chicago
to gary indiana where the gun laws are
much more relaxed it's a 40-minute drive
there's even public transit as terrible
as public transit is in this country you
can get on a bus and go from chicago to
gary
in under an hour so does it really
matter that in chicago there are on
paper strict gun laws where you can just
go 40 minutes and get your guns in
indiana case in point highland park
illinois there's a place in hammond
indiana called debs gun range okay debs
gun range is a big big gun shop
it's an 80-minute drive from highland
park illinois to deb's gun range in
hammond indiana where you can get your
guns do chicago area gun laws really
matter when in nearby indiana people
sell their weapons to other people
without background checks or paperwork
even recording the sale this is such
tired old nonsense and dick durbin he
got a piece of it right
and of course they throw it in in the
last minute they go we gotta run but
listen if the gun laws mattered then uh
why did this happen in chicago well it
was in chicago and indiana's 35 minutes
away and on and on and on and it does
not matter because these are the talking
points that the fox news audience wants
to see they want to see and hear this
pablum to make them feel good about
doing nothing about guns that's the
whole point of all of this and we should
be sick of it i'm sick of it we should
have change and
the only hope here is
that
this
decided effort from the right to do
nothing about guns
does seem to be shifting the balance of
how people plan to vote in november
against republicans the roe v wade
decision seems to be part of it doing
nothing about gun safety seems to be
part of it let's see what happens in
november
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p now this voicemail is
part of a bigger thing that happened
over the weekend there was this trump
rally in anchorage alaska i covered the
rally we had a nice audience so 15 16
000 live viewers on a random saturday
night nice audience
lots of people who don't like me and who
don't like leftism
stumbled across my live stream
and they felt furious in an entitled way
where they they spent the last two days
writing to me saying
why are you interrupting the great
president trump with your commentary one
guy even said i should leave the country
or something uh and here's another
caller who really didn't like the fact
that i covered the trump rally the way i
wanted to cover it as if you couldn't
just find another stream
you know it's painful to watch your show
because i'm trying to watch the trump
rally and all your tortoise talking over
it right making snide comments why'd you
shut the [ __ ] up and let me let us
listen
okay
watch it somewhere else
watch it somewhere else you don't have
to listen to me you don't have to watch
my stream
i'm doing my commentary and the level of
entitlement from people saying i
shouldn't be speaking over the president
just let him tell his lies unchallenged
i'll do it the way i want to do it
and even by the way maybe not
surprisingly
xenophobic
and anti-semitic responses to the fact
that i had the audacity to speak over
the great orange anointed one
uh give me a break guys i'll do the show
the way i want to do the show you can
watch somewhere else if you don't like
it we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today joe biden says he is
considering
uh declaring a health emergency over
abortion access and we're going to talk
about what that means and what might be
the result of doing that uh a pregnant
woman in texas
was pulled over in the carpool lane and
she made the argument and i believe it's
a good argument listen
uh
based on the law i have a person in my
belly right now and so therefore i
should be able to use the carpool lane
and of course this is the kind of
silliest example of the absurdity of the
right-wing personhood arguments i've
said before
listen if it's a person if the fetus is
a person they should have citizenship
if the fetus is a person
it should be entitled to child support
etc and they don't want to do any of
that but here's another just glaring
example of this absurdity why can't you
be in the carpool lane if that's a
person
uh in the womb so we will talk about
that and then number three there is a
new law in arizona seeking to limit the
recording of interactions with police
we're going to talk about the first
amendment legal community saying you
can't do that that's actually you know
for all the times that the right loves
to say that what about my first
amendment
what about my free speech they don't
know what the hell they're talking about
we have an actual first amendment issue
here which we will discuss on the bonus
show sign up at joinpackman.com
get instant access to the bonus show and
of course you can use the coupon code
big voting 22 to get yourselves a
discount we're here all week
unless anything changes and uh look
forward to seeing you tomorrow or on the
bonus show in here